et si l'on se chauffer grâce à nos
routes c'est déjà possible avec power
road développé par eurovia le concept
est simple capter la chaleur du soleil
sur les routes grâce à des tubes inséré
sous la chaussée la chaleur sera alors
stockée pury distribués via des pompes à
chaleur pour des besoins de proximité
l'été les routes vont chauffer leurs
vêtements va monter en température
environ 60 degrés donc en fait on a eu
l'idée de mettre dans la deuxième couche
de la route des tubes des tubes dans
lequel on va faire circuler un fluide
caloporteur va le faire passer dans les
sondes géothermiques on va augmenter la
température naturel de la terre qui nous
aurons autour de 15 degrés ça c'est
l'été et quand on a besoin l'hiver donc
de chauffer un bâtiment des logements
une piscine un gymnase à ce moment là on
va utiliser on va extraire les calories
qui sont dans ce volume de termes
concernés par les cendres géothermique
on va extraire avec des pompes à chaleur
d'une manière classique pour chauffer
tous ces équipements aurore bergé député
des yvelines s'est rendu à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ou le premier
démonstrateur ya été mise en service en
2018 500 m² de chaussée power road ont
été mises en place elles permettent
actuellement de chauffer un bâtiment de
370 m² et de déneiger les 500 m² de la
voirie concernés en hiver ici c'est
l'étude qui vont aller jusqu'à l'ordre
dont le seul qui revient directement ici
qui prennent un coupe ongle pour pousser
tous les fluides et gardent pas jusque
là bas dans les tubes qui souhaite ici
les sondes géothermiques vont durer plus
de 50 ans donc on aura une pompe à
chaleur a changé tous les 25 ans on va
dire mais globalement de notre
installation peut tenir entre 30 et 50
ans sans aucun souci une énergie
thermique renouvelables et invisible qui
contribuent à la transition énergétique
et à la lutte contre la précarité
énergétique
je termine c'est une chaleur
renouvelable locale qui est pour
l'instant très peu utilisé évidemment il
ya l'installation à payer mais après on
est tout simplement dans quelque chose
qui est gratuit c'est en substitution à
des énergies fossiles comme le gaz ça
permet effectivement de pouvoir réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre on
a souvent un des débats vous le savez
sur le photovoltaïque sur l'éolien à la
fois parce que c'est un coût mais aussi
sur la question des paysages là c'est
invisible cesson au pied donc on a en
plus je crois vraiment un potentiel de
développement qui est énorme la solution
power up permet d'économiser jusqu'à 80
% de co2 par rapport à une chaudière à
gaz